[Music]
in 2018 James Gunn got fired when his
original concept for Groot was revealed
now Marvel's come crawling back for one
last job and Gunn has delivered a
masterpiece at least compared to their
other crap
[Music]
I'm gonna need to take some time
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3.
the Guardians are back and since you
probably missed the Christmas special
here's a quick recap Quillen mantis are
siblings he's your brother it doesn't
matter he still doesn't listen to me
root is starting to Branch out
Drax is still Drax he'll know people
kill one guy one stupid guy who no one
loves newcomer Adam Warlock is also Drax
I said show him we mean business
although business could we have shown
here Gamora is from an alternate
timeline where she ran out of shampoo
nebula is conducting an on-screen
chemistry experiment
knock it off what and Rocket Raccoon is
a valuable piece of Ip that space Disney
will kill to get back there's no Escape
little guy we own you forever
speaking of Disney cower in fear from
orgo Corp a different child imprisoning
Corporation
and meet their CEO the high evolutionary
he set out to play God there is no God
that's why I stepped in but we'll settle
for playing Pokemon
yes he's another evil purple guy but in
a Marvel first he'll teach us that
science should only be used to keep the
status quo you didn't want to make
things perfect you just hated things the
way they are and when you think about it
that's the lesson Tony Stark taught us
too animal Blonsky and Audra Killian and
Maya Hansen and Aaron Cross and fastos
and Riri Williams and Cassie Lang and
prepare for a Rocket Raccoon origin
story full of laughs it's good to have
friends tears
Thrills tears
tears they want to kill us all in the
morning oh tears
[Music]
tears
and tears rocket yeah he's okay
in this feature length Sarah Mclaughlin
commercial for a story that gives
wholehearted support for animal rights
as long as they're cute
ever feel a little sad for them yeah
sure
to prepare for the MCU movie that you
were convinced would kill off your face
[Music]
didn't do that at all I'm okay and still
managed to be a total Downer what's even
the point of being born because quip all
you want but on a long enough timeline
everyone goes past their Prime
it gets progressively worse Britney
Spears and corn good choices
and even if you make it through all your
battles everyone you know someday will
die
forget
what was I talking about oh yeah look at
all the gears
story it's me Star-Lord sadly Cooper
Gamora the Explorer big blue
Beetleborg ladybug parenting for dummies
home to redo he's a decent villain more
or less eyebrows kid no eyebrows man Paw
Patrol Whistling Dixie you're a bad dog
Hawkeye's wife is that you Judy Greer no
seriously look it up and remember Ralph
he's back in note form
Close Encounters for a third time
[Music]
okay how does groot's language work
exactly do characters just suddenly
understand him once they become a family
I love you guys
regardless he definitely says come off
right here mantis why don't you just
touch him you know make him happy I am
Groot gross no not like that don't
adjust your timelines we track all the
dead wise Michael Caines and more across
Christopher Nolan's whole filmography in
a brand new episode of by the Numbers
click the Box on the right to watch now
I'm only here to parody trailers and
read comments and I'm all out of trailer
I am become Orbee girl the destroyer of
Barbie worlds don't tell Scotty Scotty
Doesn't Know someday we're gonna go
flying together into the forever and
beautiful sky